[Musique]
je n'ai jamais ressenti autant de fierté
ou de satisfaction qu'en accomplissant
une mission avec vous
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a fait est que je vois
quand on en est réduit aujourd'hui
essayer de faire bouger les choses dans
ce pays on n'a jamais piqué un centime
tu t'es fait tirer dessus 5 fois pour
ton pays et tu as même pas de quoi
envoyer ses gamines à la fac j'ai un job
pour toi je suis passé à autre chose
fish j'ai besoin d'un pilote et il ya le
bébé maintenant ça pourrait changer ta
vie et celle de ton monde pour de bon
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser nos
compétences pour notre propre profit ça
marche on le fait
[Musique]
je veux faire tomber gabriel martin
lauréat c'est le chef des plus gros
cartels
d'après mes estimations il ya plus de 75
millions de dollars
mais si on disparaît pas dans la nature
juste après on n'a aucune chance
après ce soir vous ne pourrez pas
reprendre une vie normale
soyez conscient on s'apprête à devenir
des criminels
tout le monde dans le bureau tout de
suite c'est un truc de malade
shi les gardes deviennent fous qu'on se
tire et on prend chacun un sac à dos
plein ça va le faire
non il ya 100 millions de dollars qui
les attendent dans le van n'est pas
question de leur laisser le moindre
billet à autre chose à proposer
on va devoir être rapide c'est pas pour
ça que j'avais signé au départ on arrête
tout la [ __ ] on s'active banier vous
tu as vu le bordel qu'on a foutu ça se
fait pas au lesparre merdier pareil il a
pas que l'argent de l'oréal ya plein
d'autres gens qui vont en avoir après
vous il nous a menti
ça sera pareil dans toutes les rues il
ya pas 36 solutions
[Musique]
toujours un peu plus compliqué que prévu
au final
un peu plus faire marche arrière
cette injure à tous est resté marqué
dessus
[Musique]